bonsoir jean pierre colombiès merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france on viens de l'entendre gabriela
natale qui défend farouchement le bilan
du gouvernement il évoque les
recrutements de nouveaux policiers les
heures supplémentaires payées en gros
personne n'avait jamais été jusque là
votre réaction
en réaction elle est un petit peu
désabusé oui mais bien évidemment qu'ils
ne vont pas ils vont pas s'auto
flageller et critiquer leurs actions au
bout de trois ans d'ailleurs il faut pas
il faut pas faire un faux procès
d'intention ou gouvernement actuel la
situation dont il hérite
elle ne date pas d'hier elle est le
résultat de plus de 20 ans de retrait
des forces de sécurité d'une grande
partie du territoire et il faudra
beaucoup plus par contre que dès que des
effets des effets d'annoncé comme ceux
auxquels auraient d'assister vous savez
de 2 milliards qui est annoncé il
faudrait voir plus en détail si on
n'assiste pas pour plutôt un glissement
de budget d'un budget à l'autre et
surtout à quoi ça va allouer ces
milliards peut-être tout simplement au
paiement dix ans supplémentaires du
reste ce sera ce sera loin très loin de
suffire pour combler le déficit
logistique dont souffre la police tente
au niveau immobilier qu'au niveau des
véhicules qu au niveau 2 de
l'informatique aux failles il ya
tellement de choses qui sont en
déshérence depuis très longtemps il
faudra pas se contenter de deux bouts de
rustines
pareil pour les dix mille dix mille
fonctionnaires dont on annonce le
recrutement est ce qu'il s'agit d'un
véritable renfort d'un ajout à des
forces existantes ou est-ce qu'on est
tout simplement dans le cadre d'un
recrutement déjà programmé faut se
méfier des effets d annonce
comme je le disais on est dans une
situation catastrophique il ya des
commissariats dans ce pays qui te sont
en état de mort cérébrale il ya
quasiment plus de fonctionnaires pour
faire tourner la boutique pour parler
crûment
donc voila quoi il faudra aller bien au
delà des déclarations de va-t-en-guerre
avec l'assurance je dirais de la volonté
inébranlable d'un gouvernement dont
d'ailleurs la colonne vertébrale
sécuritaire n'est pas n'est pas lisible
il faudrait vraiment savoir
valise gouvernement en matière de
sécurité le lien notamment entre la
citoyenneté et sa police et au passage
il faut vraiment tout le monde est en
conscience que quelle que soit la
politique sécuritaire décidé par
quelques ministres de l'intérieur que ce
soit il ne peut pas aboutir sans une
collaboration étroite avec le ministère
de la justice sur n'a pas conscience de
ça sont purement et simplement des
déclarations de principe ça veut dire
quoi concrètement évidemment vous faites
allusion voilà aux bisbilles entre le
garde des sceaux et le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin eric dupond
moretti
vous pensez que c'est un un mauvais duo
en tout cas pas l'un et l'autre pris
séparément mais que ce duo ne pourra pas
fonctionner ça vous ça vous inquiète
justement vous savez nous mais mais je
ne suis pas si on doit dire monsieur m
ou chauffe mr eric dupond-moretti
aujourd'hui mais non mais du coup du
poma eric dupond-moretti ministre de la
justice on voit bien que c'est purement
et simplement une provocation
après qu'est ce que ça cache qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que ce qu'est ce que l'on
veut faire et ce que on a procédé à ces
nominations de personnalités tellement
clivante totalement différente pour
détourner l'attention de l'opinion
publique et s'occuper d'autre chose par
ailleurs c'est assez probable scénario
qui est pas du tout incongru moi
j'attends rien et j'attends rien de ça
très concrètement j'attends rien parce
que à l'évidence il n'y a pas de volonté
ni chez lui ni chez l'autre de
déclencher de mettre en place des
réformes de fond des réformes profondes
par exemple on pourrait songer à la
dynamisation d'une filière jury du
judiciaire avec une vraie refonte des
services mais là ça nécessiterait
beaucoup d'ambitions beaucoup de moyens
beaucoup d'honnêteté morale aussi parce
que ça obligerait certains très
corporatistes à renoncer à leur acquis
et à faire fi de leurs états d'âme
on en est loin on en est très loin on
est dans une dans des guerres d'ego on
est dans des guerres d'individus de
personnalités qui ont leur profil et on
sent pas une véritable volonté de
résoudre les problèmes d'intérêts
généraux et
il n'y a pas plus grave que ça peut-être
tout simplement un manque
voilà une différence total de
philosophie entre entre ces deux
ministres quand l'un parle dans son
ouvrage sur l'autre le nid ça veut dire
en gros qu'un un qui pense nommer un
problème qui existe loki l'autre qui
finalement est dans une forme
certains diraient de dénis oui là j'ai
envie de vous dire que on est à deux on
joue un poker menteur je suis pas
certain que ni l'un ni l'autre n'ont
véritablement ni envie ni les moyens de
régler les problèmes et des défis qui
sont qui sont en face à aux politiques
actuelles dupond moretti
c'est très bien de qui il s'agit c'est
un avocat c'est pas un défenseur des
libertés publiques c'est c'est un homme
qui a défendu des clients il a défendu
des clients n'a pas défendu des
principes et monsieur darmanin est un
homme qui a été élevé si je puis dire
dans le cercle du sarkozysme donc à une
certaine époque où on l'apprenait de
manière exagérée la politique du
résultat au détriment d'une efficacité
relationnel sur le terrain donc j'ai
envie de vous dire que ni l'un ni
l'autre de toute façon nous résumerons
ne résoudrons le moindre problème
c'est une question de personnalité de
personnes c'est un fait mais c'est aussi
comme je dis je le répète ou
problématiques de vision sécuritaire il
n'y en a pas il n'y en a pas on n'a pas
l'intention on veut changer de société
on a quelque chose qui soit qui ne soit
plus justement le du ressort du pouvoir
régalien
on veut y substituer des pouvoirs de
police municipale voire de sociétés
privées donc que vous ayez monsieur
darmanin ou dupond moretti est le gisti
ça changera pas grand chose si il
faudrait vraiment réfléchir à ça à
savoir ce que monsieur macron plus tôt a
derrière la tête lorsqu il nomme des
personnalités comme celle ci que tout
oppose et au final vous voyez le débat
tourne autour de ça finalement on se
demande s'ils vont finir par s'entendre
mais on ne pose pas la question de
savoir quelle est leur vision de la
société de demain
alors il ya
curiosité également en ce moment eric
dupond moretti qui nous dit que les
chiffres relatés la violence n'ont pas
augmenté et puis à le fameux ressenti un
petit peu comme la météo
quel est votre avis de deux policiers là
tu es ce que oui et non la violence
selon vous selon le policier que vous
êtes a augmenté en france
elle s'est surtout banalisé et elle
s'est surtout développée sans aucun
risque de pénalités c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui des gens commettent de façon
régulière des actes de violence sans
qu'ils n'encourent la moindre peine de
prison effective jeudi bien effective
parce que contrairement à ce qu'a dit
monsieur dupont moretti
c'est pas vrai que 92% des peines sont
sont appliquées c'est faux quelqu'un qui
est condamné à un an de prison ferme ne
les fera pas tout simplement parce que
il ya des barèmes il y à il ya des
curseurs en deçà desquels on devra tout
simplement pas incarcérer des individus
donc vous avez des gens qui se sont
installés depuis très longtemps
maintenant dans une dynamique de
délinquance dont ils n'ont absolument
pas envie de sortir
c'est pour ça que ce débat est tronqué
d'ailleurs par ailleurs on en met en
avant le chômage la précarité sociale
c'est fou c'est faux il ya des gens qui
sont tout simplement installé dans le
système de la délinquance comme moyens
d'existence
normal donc il faudra bien autre chose
pour je dirais non pas les faire revenir
dans le droit chemin s'ils n'ont pas du
tout envie mais pour les neutraliser
donc on n'est pas du tout dans du
ressenti là c'est une réalité
la violence elle est là bon c'est sûr
que si on compare la situation de
criminels de la france où dix neuvième
siècle par rapport à aujourd'hui
c'est sans commune mesure ce serait
d'ailleurs stupide de jouer ce petit jeu
là mais il ya aujourd'hui c'est fait
une banalisation de la violence et de la
délinquance qui est devenu tout à fait
con con qu'on passe notre temps à
excuser a légitimé à a tenté de
neutraliser médiatiquement s'entend mais
pas du tout neutraliser juridiquement
non loin la banalisation de la violence
contre la police
également et vice versa diraient
certains de vos détracteurs coûté la
violence contre des policiers à ma
connaissance n'est pas toujours suivi
d'incarcération ça c'est un fait
armasuisse mois par contre lorsque des
faits de violence sont avérés contre des
policiers je défends pas tous attention
on passe plus pas se méprendre ce que je
vais vous dire lorsque des faits de
violence ou de défaut de graver son sang
sont avérés les policiers sont
poursuivis et pour beaucoup sont
révoqués donc il faut aussi de faire
croire ou de laisser croire qu'il y ait
une impunité totale des actes de
violences policières après que le
système soit un parfait on va pas dire
le contraire
ces derniers mois il ya une dérive dans
l'utilisation des forces de maintien de
l'ordre
on a glissé vers des méthodologies
d'emploi des forces de sécurité sur le
terrain qui sont très discutables
là encore ça répondait à une volonté
politique faut pas ce faux pas se
leurrer et donc il faut il faudra
réfléchir à tout ça et là je mets en
garde
je mets en garde sur le flip bashing et
sur le fait de gt l'institution avec
l'eau du bain se serait pas une bonne
idée
ce sont ces la philosophie globale qu'il
faut changer qui qu'il faut adapter
en d'autres termes mettre les politiques
devant leurs responsabilités avant toute
chose et pas simplement s'attarder à des
fautes individuelles sur le terrain je
n'aurais peut être qu'ils sont pas du
tout excusable dans certains cas pour
d'autres c'est beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus sujet à discussion mais il faut que
chacun soit face à ses responsabilités
et là j'ai vite à ce que cette
responsabilité soit réellement posée au
niveau des donneurs d'ordres ne sera pas
mal merci beaucoup
jean-pierre colombien s'est en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous nous avoir apporté
votre point de vue